man ist dir das noch
[Musik]
weil das ist cool ich mag immer so
sachen die man so echt essen kann zu
probieren
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich war heute ein
schulungs torte denn die gibt es
tatsächlich noch gar nicht auf meinem
kampf und ich hab ich über instagram
gefragt möchtet ihr noch eine sehen bzw
was oder wie soll sie seien viele haben
tatsächlich geschrieben bitte eine
einfache ohne von dann ich muss sagen
ich muss da jetzt ein bisschen was im
fondant machen weil das muss ja auch
optisch einfach nach einschulung
schreien aber die torte an sich ist
super anfänger geeignet und einfach und
ihr bekommt sie ganz schnell hin wenn
ihr euch schritt für schritt einfach an
die anleitung halten ich schreibe euch
die ganz genauen mengenangaben wie immer
unten in die infobox und ich starte
jetzt auch direkt ich benutze meine
küchenmaschine ihr dürft aber auch sehr
gerne handrührgerät verwenden nicht nur
dafür die eier gut wäre wenn alle acht
wenn alle temperatur wenn alle zutaten
auf zimmertemperatur während für den
teig dann verbindet sich das nämlich
nachher besser und ich gebe zu den eiern
eine prise salz und zucker
und dann schlage ich das auch auf
maximaler geschwindigkeit schon so
sieben acht minuten
[Musik]
die eimasse ist so richtig schön hell
und dick cremig genauso ist ja auch
richtig als nächstes kommen
sonnenblumenöl und milch dazu das
übrigens ein wunder kuchen rezept das
heißt ihr könnt jetzt statt der milch
auch jede andere flüssigkeit nehmen
vielleicht auch einfach mal fragen was
das ein schulungs kind mag wenn es das
besagte orangensaft oder maracuja saft
könnte das auch gerne mit rein arbeiten
und damit das ganze nochmal einen
besseren geschmack bekommt gebe ich
vanille extrakt und
zitronen passte mit rein ihr könntet
auch zitronenschalen abgibt dazu geben
aber ich habe es gerade diese diese
passte da ich verlinke ich auch gerne in
die infobox genauso wie alle anderen
utensilien und dann verrät dass
anschließend kommen die trockenen
zutaten dazu und die bestehen einfach
nur aus mehl und backpulver
[Musik]
die trockenen zutaten auch nur ganz kurz
unter rühren grad so lange bis sie sich
verbunden haben jetzt ist der tag auch
schon fertig ist nun wirklich ruckzuck
ich habe übrigens meine 20 cm springform
vorbereitet indem ich den boden mit
backpapier ausgekleidet und auch noch
die seiten
[Musik]
für den teig jetzt ein ich muss dazu
sagen dass meine springt form einen sehr
hohen rand hat und ich habe mir wirklich
gedanken gemacht als ich dieses rezept
mir überlegt habe ja wie mache ich das
ich will zeit wirklich so einfach wie
möglich machen menschen die auch nicht
so unendlich viel equipment da haben und
ich würde eigentlich sogar in zwei toren
bringen oder in zwei springform backen
habe jetzt bewusst darauf verzichtet
damit ebenso viele leute wie möglich das
nachmachen können die eben das equipment
nicht da haben daher achtet darauf dass
er das springen vom mit hohem rand
verwendet und die sollten auch nochmal
einkleidet weil bei mir nach dem backen
wird er schon wirklich bis fast über am
rand gehen ja das wird ein sehr hoher
boden und der wird jetzt gemacht und bei
170 grad ober und unterhitze im
vorgeheizten backofen ganz wichtig für
60 minuten allerdings nach 45 minuten
schon eine alufolie oben drüber machen
aber es zeige ich euch gleich
[Musik]
so wir machen in der zwischenzeit zumal
die creme da hab ich mir auch etwas ganz
einfaches überlegt und zwar wird es eine
buttercreme mitbenutzen er später noch
vom band deshalb ist es halt super
buttercreme zu benutzen damit man keine
angst hat dass sich der verband diese
die deko sich auflöst und dafür nehmen
wir uns zimmer warme butter die wird in
der küchenmaschine oder mit dem
handrührgerät sehr lange geschlagen die
muskel richtig schön hell cremig werden
weiß werden und das ist immer auch der
fehler den viele machen die sagen okay
die buttercreme schmeckt sehr nach
butter das tut sie wenn man sie nicht
lange genug schlägt daher gibt im ganzen
ruhig so acht bis neun minuten zeit ihr
könnt jetzt gerne noch eine prise salz
mit reingeben ich habe mir schon
gesalzene butter daher verzichte ich
darauf und später kommt noch gezuckerte
kondensmilch dazu
[Musik]
ihr dürft auch gerne mal probieren denn
die schmeckt jetzt ganz andere gar nicht
mehr dieser typische buttergeschmack um
sondern eher so neutral und dem abgang
diese ganz feine aber leckere butter
note also nicht dieses was man sich
vorstellt ihr könnt euch jetzt butter in
den boden so zu sagen sondern als das
total angenehm und jetzt kommen die
gezuckerte kondensmilch noch rein
[Musik]
ich habe die gezuckerte kondensmilch
übrigens noch zwei minuten lang mit der
butter zusammenschlagen lassen ist
brauchen wir nicht mehr die maschine ich
werde das ganze jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen auflockern und gibt da doppel
rahmen frischkäse dazu es wird auch
mascarpone ganz gut passen beim
frischkäse benutze ich zb jetzt
philadelphia ganz gerne weil er einfach
nicht so salzig ist und das richtet mit
dem schneebesen nur noch ganz kurz ein
und ich werde das ganze noch mit vanille
extrakt verfeinern damit auch
geschmacklich noch mal auf ein neues
level gehoben wird
[Musik]
ihr könnt natürlich diese buttercreme
jetzt auch einfärben dann sieht's auch
nochmal farbtechnik ein bisschen
schicker aus und verspielter ich hab
dafür einfach nur meine nichte geschickt
denn sie litt er eingeschult bzw sogar
zwei männer nicht nur die probieren auch
am ende des videos und mal gucken sie
hat mir ist ein audio geschickt man
gucken was ihre lieblingsfarbe ist mein
liebling ist
perfekt also wird das pink eingestellt
eingefärbt und das geht auch ganz easy
einfach ein paar tropfen lebensmittel
vorbereiten und dann kurz verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt kommt eine ganz einfache art und
weise fondant deko für unsere tochter
herzustellen ich habe mich für stifte
und bücher entschieden das sind die
stifter die habe ich gestern schon mal
vorbereitet und das ist eigentlich so
dass zeit aufwendigste wobei hierfür
habe ich zum beispiel so ein gute
eineinhalb stunden gebraucht dadurch
braucht eineinhalb stunden band und ich
finde das geht klar wenn man vom vortag
macht und er braucht auch nicht so
spezielles equipment ich nehme mir jetzt
hier mein von dann den habe ich schon
eingefärbt und werde erst mal einen
langen strang daraus rollen vorher schon
weiß kneten und ich mache so dass ich
die arbeitsfläche immer mit ein bisschen
kokosfett netze und auch die hände denn
dann gibt es auch nicht an
wenn ihr zu viel fett habt oder ihr
merkt das ist zu weich dann könnt ihr
mit ein bisschen puderzucker
gegensteuern
wird der strang einmal durchgeschnitten
das muss auch gar nicht alles gleich
lang sein denn die stifter dürfen ja
auch unterschiedlich genutzt werden
nämlich dass das käppi ihr könnt auch
normales messer nehmen und dann einfach
hier unregelmäßige streifen schneiden
und als nächstes nehmen uns einmal diese
braune spitze und dadurch dass jetzt
zehn minuten trocknen konnte ist es auch
ein bisschen einfacher mit dem handling
deswegen einfach hier vorne bis man es
gerade abschneiden die spitze da muss
auch was abgeschnitten werden denn da
kommt ja die mine gleich noch mal drauf
und ich nehme jetzt einfach einen feinen
pinsel und etwas leitungswasser und gibt
das hier vorne an die spitze des stiftes
und gibt es einfach dran und in dem ihr
das dann noch mal rollt wird der stift
erstens ein bisschen dünner und zweitens
schmiegt sich das dann perfekt an dann
kommt noch die spitze drauf und auf der
unterseite werde ich auch noch ein
bisschen vom frauenverband machen
[Musik]
als nächstes mache ich die kleinen
feinen bücher dafür einfach den weißen
von daneben 3 mm dick ausrollen ich
mache das alles nach augenmaß
für den umschlag nämlich dann bomben von
dann klappt das um ihr könnt dann noch
ein bisschen details einarbeiten und
dann sind sie auch schon fertig also ihr
müsst ja wirklich einfach nur noch augen
machen ist es wirklich total easy
[Musik]
ich habe die bücher jetzt auch schon
vorbereitet und macht weiter mit dem
boden der ist jetzt gebacken er ist auch
sehr hoch geworden und außerdem habt ihn
vollständig abkühlen lassen also einmal
den ring entfernen bzw die ganze
springform einmal entfernt dann werde
ich den boden einteilen dafür nehme ich
meine torten säge und dann geht so ganz
erfüllen
[Musik]
als nächstes wird die torte geschichte
ich mache es so dass ich ihnen die
zwischenschichten noch
aprikosenmarmelade gebe das gibt noch
mal so einen fruchtigen kick und dann
einfach schichten bis hier oben
angekommen seid und rundherum
einstreichen ihr müsst euch beim
einstreichen jetzt nicht so viel mühe
geben denn das wird ein bisschen
improvisations mäßig aussehen also
bewusst denn wir nehmen uns jetzt die
stifte und die bücher ich habe auch noch
ein paar zahlen und buchstaben
ausgestochen und der kurier nicht
einfach wild herum ich habe mir aber
auch noch ein bisschen von der creme mit
dem sie den rest in einen spritzbeutel
mit französischer stern telefone
drangegeben um dann nochmal die
oberfläche zu dekorieren
[Musik]
wir kommen jetzt zur verkostung und wir
haben hier zwei jurymitglieder
so wie ihr seid nett oder und er lässt
dürfte sein also das sind unser sonst
erlischt das ist ja der
46 und das ist ein jahr alt und beide
werden bald eingeschult
setzt die torten dürfte probieren dürfen
ganz ehrlich sein will sie findet und
wie schmeckt
welche
genau wer ich war gefragt und von den
beiden lieblingsfarbe ist rosa und
pinken und
liegt sagen
ist dass er vom probieren kann man damit
auch morgen gegen
8 vorstellen aus warum
nein mit linz noch
ja ich weiß dass ich cool ich mag immer
so sachen die man so echt essen kann zum
beispiel diese bücher kann man es nicht
gerne dafür
das buch kannst du dann auch ist genau
der stift und den start das ist cool
da schmeckt so nach erdbeben oder so
ja
freut es uns schon jetzt ja
wenn ihr die bücher ist bei uns immer
schlauer
sodann verabschiedet und von dem
publikum und ihr könnt gleich in ruhe zu
ende essen wir wünschen allen
erstklässlern eine schöne schulzeit also
bis zum nächsten mal
gemeinsam
ist sie das noch
[Musik]